お釈迦様がこのスベという青年に
自分たちのスベさんの先生たちのことをかなり激しくからかったんですね
このブラマン人という人々が
ブラマン人という人々が
この善というものについて
善と悪の場合はね まあそれは皆さん
私よりそういう詳しく知っていると思いますけど
倫理学ではまあ善と悪の定義っていうのは厳しく考えるテーマですからね
まあ西洋哲学でもそうやってるみたいし
うん で 善の場合はまあ善
良いことの定義として
ブラマン人が何か決めてあったんですね
五つのこと その五つはこの一番目はサッチャン
真理ですね だから真理を求めることが善であって
という善でありますと
だから真理を求めないことは
そうすると論理的に悪になるんですね
真理そのものが善ですね
二番目はタパン タパンっていうのは修行でもあるし
やっぱりまあタパスというのは
まあやっぱり燃やすというかね
温か まあ火で炙ることなんですね
結局は だからこの それで心をやっぱりいくらか炙っておかないと
心の悪さがなくならないんですね
まあ例えば 片一なんかは曲がることはできません
それでまあ火で炙って
ゆっくりと曲げて 何か形をとって必要な形にする
そうすると何か役に立ちますね
で 弓なんか矢なんか作る場合は
真っすぐにしておかないと動かない
だから木の枝をまた火で炙ってまっすぐにする
そういう風に調整することがタパスですね
だからこの まあ日本語ではまあ苦行という風に専門家が訳していますけどね
まあ日本語で苦行かもしれませんだけど
もともとの言葉通りの
まあ私達の間違っているかもしれませんだけど
意見ではタパスというのはこのタパですから
まあ温めることなんですね
ですから 昔はこの温めていろんなものを調整するんですよ
今はないかもしれませんだけど
やっぱりこの刃物やらいろんなものを作ろうと思っちゃうと
まずものすごく温めちゃいますね
温めてからそれ叩いたり
まあいろんな他の鉄分やらいろんなものをまあ繋げたりして
刃物を作ったりする ですから
その昔の まあ人間の まあ日常生活の中で役に立たないものは役に立つようにする過程なんですね
それは鉄だけじゃなくて
まあ金属だけではなくて
この木材の場合でも同じことなんですね
やっぱり温めて温めて調整して
で 必要な形に変えたりします
でないと 木はそのものは別になんの役にも立たないと思います
で 木はね まあ椅子を作ったり
ベッドを作ったり あらゆるタンスを作ったりとか
あらゆる家具を作るためには木材を使いましても
そのままでタンスになるわけじゃないんだから
やっぱりあらゆる工程を経なくちゃいけないんですね
で その中の一つっていうのは
まあ特に曲げてもらう場合は
やっぱり温めないと 温めると見事に曲げちゃいます
葉っぱでもすぐ破れる葉っぱがいっぱいありますけど
温めたら破れませんね
好きな形に曲がることはできます
穴も開けませんね で それはまあまあ料理なんかの場合でもまあ使うと思いますけども
笹の葉っぱやら何でも
まあそんな簡単にいろいろ形に作るってことはできませんだけど
一応蒸し器で蒸してもらっちゃうと
まあどんな形にももう曲げることはできます
柔軟性になるようになります
それでまあ心の場合は
心はそのまんまではまあ役に立たない悪であると
その悪というふうな心をまず二番目として
炙ってみるんですね で
そうすると必要な形に必要なように調整することができるんだよと
それはタパスということで温めるって意味で専門用語として使わない
まあ修行ということなんです
元の意味はそういう意味
言葉の辞書の意味はそういう意味なんですね
だから番目は これが二番目で
まあ三番目はブラフマチャリアですね
まあブラフマチャリアはやっぱり欲に溺れないで
あの 独立して生活することで
四番目はこのアッジヘサナン
よく勉強することですね
で 勉強することをブラマン人がこの善行為として見ていることで
やはり一つ一つを決して根拠のないものではありません
人は何一つも勉強しないと良い人間になるわけじゃありません
だから いろんなことを勉強すると
それによって人格が良くなるんですよ
ですから この勉強する
あらゆることを勉強する
その勉強することによって立派な人間にまります
だからそれが禅の道ですね
で 5番目はこのチャガ
より立派な人間になってくる
やっぱり自分のために生きてるんじゃなくて
チャガっていうのは布施のことで
やっぱり他人のために生きてみるっていうことになるんですね
だから他人のために生きてみることで
まあ一番基本的な単純明快なことは布施ですよ
何かあげるということね
しかし まあそれをただあげるだけの意味ではなくて
人間は生まれてきた人間が
まあ何の役にも立たない
だらしない 悪の塊という立場にとって
その人がまあいろいろ工夫して立派な人になる
善の人間になる そのためには道が 5つというか
方法は 5つありまして
この 5つもやらなくちゃいけないですね
まず真理を認める 求めることで
まあそれからまあ修行したりすることで
それから欲のない生活をね
汚れてない生活をしてみることで
それから勉強することで
あらゆる知識をね 得ることで
5番目に人の役に立つように生きてみる
その 5つで まあ善は完成するんだよと
ということは もうバラモン人の世界であった考え方なんですね
その 5つはどう見たって別に問題あるわけじゃないんですから
お釈迦様はそれを否定してるわけじゃないんです
否定してないんだけど
お釈迦様はなんかこれは非難
批判するんですね その批判する仕方が何なのかと
どんな風に批判したんですかね
その教えは 覚えてますか？お釈迦様はその 5つは否定してないんですよ
5つの項目は否定してない
しかし バラモン人を馬鹿にしているんです
あれほど大事な教えを教えているのに
まあそれはまあ仏教の人はすごくブッダの教えとしてはね
仏教ではなくてね ブッダに対してはすっごい大事なポイントなんです
それは実証していますか？という言葉なんですね
実証していますか？証明していますか？正しいと
だから このブッダのこの科学的なアプローチっていうのはそういうとこなんです
いくら理論があっても
その理論が正しいと実験で実験で実証しておかないと
ということなんですね
伝統は悪いと言ってるんじゃないんです
例えばこの鉄やら真鍮やらね
まあいろいろものを組み合わせて
3ヶ月間炉で溶かしておくと金になるんだよと言っちゃえば
昔あったんですね そういう錬金術と術というものがね
だからまあいろいろリストもありますよ
これこれこれこれと組み合わせて
こういうこういう風にこういう風にすれば
まあ金属は金になりますよと
それで秘密の薬やらいろんなものがあったりして
まあそのリストはある
ていって 本当にその何か何か組み合わせて金属を合成したところで金になるんですかと
それはちゃんと実験して実証しておかないと
だから普通の化学の学校の授業でやってることをやってないと
例えば酸素っていうのは物は燃やしますよと
ああそうですか はい分かりましたと
そんなのは科学的な勉強になりません
それでちゃんと酸素を作って
まあそちらに何か火の玉でも何か入れちゃうところで
ボーンと燃え上がっちゃうでしょうに
それではなるほど 酸素は物は燃やすとということになります
塩素はひどい臭いするそうと
はい 分かりましたということになりません
それだったら塩素を作って
もう嗅いでみない限りはひどい臭いするかということはわからないんですね
だから このまあ 単純なこの化学やら物理学やら
そういう授業でいろんな理論は言いますよ
金属を温めたらもう伸びますよとかね
それでちゃんと温めて測ってみせるんですよ
これぐらい伸びたよとかね
だから実験してみないと正しいかないかっていうことはわからないんです
それは真理に迫るいてどうしても必要なことなんです
物理学のことだけ実験して証拠を出しても
心のことは冗談大内蔵と言ったって何の意味もないんです
もし心のことも真理であるならば
同じく実験で試すことができるはずなんです
だから実験していない理論はもうブッダはもう捨てるんですよ
うわごとやと そこら辺はお釈迦様が言いたがってるポイントなんです
人々はいくらでも仮説やら
こうではなかろう ああではなかろうというのは妄想できますからね
何でも妄想できますよ
現代時代 現代社会を見ると
もうあらゆる考え方もあるはあるはあるはあるは
あまりにももうもうもう怠け者たちだからね
現代人というのはものすごい激しく妄想する
だから妄想するだけでかなり金儲けているんでしょうね
あることもないこと妄想できれば
いとも簡単にこの記者になりますよ
ジャーナリストに 上手に嘘を言えるんだったら
もう日本では立派なジャーナリストになります
何もデータいりません
ただ妄想して書く 時々何一つもデータがないのに
ばっかでかい新聞柄も表面全部もう埋め込んであるんですよ
昔ある新聞で買うことは絶対しませんだから私はね
新聞雑誌は コンピューター関係のものはたまにもうデータ何か知りたい場合は買いますけど
でももう腹が立ちます
買ってからはね 円 八百円払ったんだけど
私に必要のはもうただページの半分ぐらいなんです
それだったらもう店で読んだ方がいいんじゃないかなと
しかし それはもう礼悪いしね
で 盗むことですからね
まあ買いますけど その半分のデータ取るために開ければ切るは切るは
これからまあ八ページぐらいもう宣伝で
これからまたない またない
またないと 一行二行でもう書くものなんですけど
これは二十ページぐらい使ったりするしね
まあそれはもう置いておいで
だからもう買いませんだけど
でもまあ 買いませんと言ったっても
絶対的に買いませんではなくて
買うものもありますからね
それ言っただけで もう何でも条件付きだから
ある日 電車で新聞のフロントページと言いますか
表面で昔の話でね 麻原は私は死にたくないと大きいタイプばっかでかい文字で
麻原が泣き崩れると これどこで誰から聞いて言ってるんですかね
麻原が逮捕されてもう何ヶ月
一ヶ月とかも経ったところで
この麻原のニュースがもう売れるんだから
麻原に会うこともできない
どんなジャーナリストであろうとも
であいつは弁護士もグルグル変わったりすると
頭がイカれて悪い弁護士がついていたし
もうその人も自分が何喋ってるか分からないし
もうぴったし合うんですね
麻原と で だから彼が弁護士の決まりとして
こう言ったああ言ったとかはね
一般人には言ってはいけないんでしょうね
だから一応彼が言わないということはもう推測できる
では ジャーナリストにそんなことは誰が言うんですかね
よくも平気で堂々と裏付けも何もないものを頭で考えて書くこと
で 裏付けはこれなんですね
麻原も一応沈黙と言うんですか
守ってるんですね 何も言わないっていうことは
それは日本の法律で一つ認めている一つの権利ですね
自分の都合に悪いことっていうのは言わなくてもよろしいと
犯人かないかっていうのは
調べるのはこれは警察の仕事やということで
私は犯人だよと言わなくたってもいいんです
だから 自分の立場に悪いと思ったら黙っていることはできるし
どうしても喋らなくちゃいけない場合は
弁護士通して喋るということは
もう法律で認められた権利なんだよね
それがそう言っている彼が何一つもいまだに喋ってないんですね
それで推測するんですね
だからこの人は処刑になる
どうやって処刑になるかと今決められますかね
彼が直接関係してないんだから
それはわからないでしょうね
裁判はどんな判断をするかっていうことは
はっきりした証拠をね
もう殺せと言いましたよとかね
ということない限りはね
間接的な証拠で そう簡単じゃないんですよ
とにかくそういうふうに決めつけて
そうするとおそらく彼が怖くなるでしょうと
それで泣き崩れたと すごいドラマティックに
みんななるほどこいつは偉そうにって読んだりする
そこは言ったのは やっぱりこの何だかんだ言っても
現代人っていうのはものすごいドラマティックに妄想する
だから事実ですかと だからそこでまあ書くのは自由だからね
それにはこちらで反対する権利はないんですけど
好き勝手に何だ書いたって
もう勝手に書けばよろしいんですよ
しかし 我々は一応新聞を読んで情報を受ける側なんですね
だから新聞であったんだからって事実かと
そういうことで この妄想するという恐ろしい世界に我々は生きているんですね
それでまあ宗教があっちこっち現れてくるわ
いろんなもう新しい宗教ではなくて
古い宗教にしたってもね
一応いろんな宗教 キリスト教からもうむちゃぐちゃ
いろんなよく伝統がありますよと言って
いろんなことをしゃべるは
もう密教 仏教からティベット仏教から
こういうティベットの坊主がこれ言った
それ言ったとかね いろんなことが出てくる
それで全く無批判であ
素晴らしい人ではない
ああ素晴らしいすごい人ではないかとかね
で そんな感じで鵜呑みにする
それが仏教ではないと
ものすごい厳しく そこら辺は気をつける世界なんですね
でないと理性の人間にはなりません
だから みんなブッダのことを嫌いになっても
仏教はめげません 仏教が目指しているのは理性を持つ人間なんですね
理性を持つ人間になるためには
妄想するのではなくて
ちゃんと証拠データがあったところだけ
あ それは知ってるんだよと
それ以上かすかにでも持っていってはいけない
少々数学的な推測は認めます
例えば数学でも推測できますけど
その場合はある決まりがあって
その決まり自体が正しいとまず証拠をする
証拠を出す それからその決まりはいろんなものに当てはめてもいい
例えば無限という言葉
数学ではあるでしょうに
でも誰もそれは実証したことはないでしょうに
確かに無限という数字があるんだよと
ないんですよ そんな数字は
ないんだけど 数学的には成り立ちます
それが嘘かというと嘘ではありません
無限っていうのはいつも簡単に成り立つんです
成り立つんだけど 証拠は出せません
だからそこは推測と呼ぶんですね
で そういう推測は数学的で
それは別に事実ではありませんということは
まあ言いにくい それはこの現代
この宇宙科学とか いろんなことをやってる人々みたいに
やたらに無差別にやってる妄想
推測とは違いますね あの考古学
宇宙学 そういう人々というのはやたらに妄想する
でもそれであれやこれやとか
すごいドラマティックに昔の科学テキストなんかはそんなドラマティックではなかったんで
今はもうドラマそのもの
漫画そのものですよ 簡単に読める
だからこの仏教はそうやっていくのはもう限りなくいろんなことを妄想
推測するっていうことは
まあちょっと ちょっとではなくて
このお話でよくないと思ってるんですね
そこはどれほど厳しいかというと
この五つのこの善に至る項目
だからこれはもう善は何ですか
悪は何ですかっていうのは
この倫理学の世界でなかなか未だにはっきりしていないんですね
善悪の基準というのは
でも原始的なインド人やら仏教の世界では
もうそれははっきりしているんですね
で 現代哲学ははっきりするのは良くないんだと
そういう立場を取っているし
だから自分たちの頭がもうなんかもうボロ切れ状態ですから
どこから取ってももう破れちゃうというね
だからもう言ってる考え方もそんな調子でなきゃ良くないっていう立場取ってるかもしれませんだけど
昔の人々はね まあまあしっかり考えていたんだから
やっぱりブラマン人はね
仏教ではないんですよ
ブラマン人ははっきりと五つの項目を言っている
その項目は まあ仏教の立場から見ても決して悪いとは言えませんし
よく立派にまとめているということも言えるんですよ
例えば まあ西洋的な人間の考え方
皆様方知ってるならば
この真理というものというのは
このやっぱりwisdomということなんです
だからアリストテレスからね
で 西洋哲学を発展したのは
このwisdomというものを目指したんだからなんです
本当のことを探しましょうと
知恵ってのは大事ですよと
だからそれは西洋文化そのものなんです
今現代の 知恵を探し求める wisdom
を探し求める wisdom
というもののためなら
もう何でも破壊して壊してやるぞと
だから神であろうが教会であろうか
全然気にしない もうもう調べて調べて探し求めていってしまって
もう科学も発展しましたし
哲学も発展しましたし
だからこの西洋文化の発展の原因は
このただwisdomというその言葉なんですよ
軽い言葉はknowledgeというか
まあ知恵ですね まあ仏教でいう知恵は別な専門用語だからね
それは使う必要ないんですけど
まあ一般的にいう知恵
真理 だから知恵はもっと正しく日本語にしちゃうと真理っていうことは
本当のことは何なのかと
それをいろんな実験で
哲学思考で あらゆる面で
まあ西洋人がもう頑張って考えたんですね
ギリシャ哲学からの 時代は仏教の時代とはほぼ初めは同じ時代でしたけど
まあ仏教の場合はもうすぐ答え見つけて終わり終了しましたってことになっちゃったんだからね
まあそれで終わってしまったんですね
西洋人はもう考えることでも十分やと思っていたんだから
いまだに考えているんですね
だから考えることにはキリがないし
何でも考えられるんだから
まあこれ最初からもう仏教はもう置いておいたんですね
だからどうしてもそれは妄想になってしまう
で そういうことですから
このwisdomという
あの なんていうか サッチャン
真理 それが善の善だよと言ったところは
私はブラマン人の思考の中でも大したもんだなと思いますよ
それが西洋文明の文化の
もうそれそのたったそのポイントで発展したんだから
それで終わらないでさらにいろんなことを言うでしょうに
タパスということ 修行ということ
そこは西洋ではない真理で終わっちゃってるんですよ
タパスということは 自分自身を育てることなんですね
人間が生まれたまんまでもう完璧というわけじゃないんだと
役に立たない植物 森の中にある木と同じ状態だと
それを温めたり切ったり
いろんなことを削ったり磨いたり
いろんなことをして 役に立つような必要な道具を作るような感じで
心も温めたり伸ばしたり縮ませたり
いろんなことをして 役に立つような柔軟性のある心に育てると
それが善ですよと それからブラフマチャリーヤ
またすごい立派なことでしょうに
心育てる上で そこら辺は論理的に噛み合わないところありますよ
それは仏教から見れば噛み合わないところありますけど
仏教だったら順番変わるんですよ
だからまあ それはそれで別に置いておいて
順番がどうでもよろしいし
で ブラフマチャリアっていうことを入れているでしょ
ブラフマチャリアっていうのは清らかな生き方でしょ
人間がまた感情で酒飲みたくなったら飲むわ
怒りたくなったら怒るわ
欲を出したくなる時は出すと
そんなのは自然だ 自然だとかね
その気持ちもただ正直な気持ちではないかと
それだったらダメやと
いくら正直な気持ちだと言ったってもね
自分をなんていうの 制御する必要あるんだよっていうことはブラフマチャリアなんですね
欲が生まれたんだからといって
それはもうやってやるぞというのはよくない
でもやっぱり西洋心理学ではそれは抑えてはいけませんと
抑えちゃうと病気になるんだぞということを言ってますけど
それはもともと色欲喚起ない世界だからそうなっていて
色欲喚起ある世界では決して欲を抑えたことで病気になった精神的な病気になった人はいなかったんですね
今はいますけどね 今 西洋文化だから
インドでもスリランカでもどこでも
だから精神病院っていうのはもうかなり発展して繁栄しています
それはまあ 西洋文化ですからね
しかし昔はね 欲を抑えたんだからといって
精神的に病気になったっていうことは
これはもうありえないんですよ
例えば若者に誰か見たところで
すごく欲が出てきたってのは
その若者も道徳的に讃えて訓練させているんだからね
で よく知ってるんで これはいけないことやと
ということで あまり問題にならない
ところでブラフマチャリアっていうものを入れたりしてね
それからアッジェーサなんていうのは立派なことでしょうね
特にバラモン人の場合は勉強好きな人々でしょうし
バラモン人になるならば勉強しなくちゃいけないという
だから昔は仕事を分けていたんだからね
みんな勉強する必要ない
社会の一部は知識人で
彼らが専門的に知識人で知識仕事をするというふうなカースト制度ですから
バラモン人は自分のカーストに決められた職業として勉強しなくちゃいけない
だから彼らが勉強も大事な道徳のポイントの一つとして入れてある
で 現代人から見ても 勉強する人が勉強しない人よりはマシでしょうし
何の勉強しないよりはね
だからもう何でもいいんだから
勉強して視野を広げましょうっていうところは決して悪くはない
だから この 5つの項目を一つ一つ見てみても
なんか見事に善と悪の判別をね
してるんではないかなと
理屈では分かります それぐらい立派な項目なのに
ブッダがそちらにはケチをつける
単純にああ これぐらいのことだったら別に私も反対しませんよと言った方が良かったのに
そう単純じゃないんだよ
お釈迦様 こちらにあるのはある理論なんですよ
道徳理論なんですよ ではこの道徳理論
どうやって作ったんですか？と聞くんですよ
ちゃんと確かめ-これが正しいと実証したんですかと
だから我々の考え方から見れば
もっともらしい思考やと言っても気をつけなさいと
だから私たちに生きてる世界では
なんかまとめな考え方ですよとか
あるいはもうもっともらしいですよとかね
あるいは理屈通ってますよと思うことっていうのは
いくらでもあります いくらでもありますよ
どんな宗教の本を読んでみたっても
キリスト教であろうが
イスラム教であろうが
いろんな仏教の宗派であろうが
まあ読んだだけで なるほど立派なことを言っているではないかと
でもブッダはそれが甘いんだと
それが危険だと その納得いったといけとも簡単に
いても簡単に納得いくなよと
物事は真理がないかっていうのは
実証しない限りはわからないもんだよと
そういうわけで その実証という一言葉っていうのは
もうものすごく徹底的に仏教には必要なんです
科学よりも仏教には必要なんです
実証するかしないかと
理屈だけでは絶対ダメですよと
すごい見事に納得いけるお説法だよと言ったってもとんでもないやと
そんなことは お釈迦様がやっぱり素晴らしい教えだよということでは
もう納得いかないんですね
例えば昔のバラモンの方々は
仙人の方々は教えたものだよと言っても納得はしません
たったこのジリジリの証拠なくてもいいんです
お釈迦様には この人間の世界で
それはちょっと無理っていうことをわかってます
例えば地球が丸いっていうことは
人間みんな知っておかなくちゃあかんと言っても
これが無理でしょうに
だから人間の中でたった一人だけでも宇宙に行って
やっぱり地球は丸いと言えば
それだけでも十分だよと
たった一人だけでも宇宙に行って
地球を見て やっぱり丸くて青いんだよと
写真撮ってくれれば それぐらいでも納得いきますよと
自分で行ってみなきゃという
そういう頑固さもないんですよ
そこまではない だからこの青年に聞くんですよ
一人でもこの 5つの項目こそが善に至る道だよと自分で実証して発見して
知り尽くして言ってますかと
言うと 誰もそんなことは言ってないということでしょ
ということは その人々はそう思っているということになるんです
この人が自分で一生懸命考えるところ
やっぱり人間っていうのは真理やと一人のバラモン人が言ったりして
そこは自分の弟子に言ったところで真理だけで足らんなと思ったところで
やっぱり真理知るためには頑張らないと
では修行もありますよと修行を付け加える
そこで弟子に教えると
3番目の弟子がやっぱり修行したっても
ちゃんとした道徳的な生き方がないと修行は成り立たんでしょうね
欲に溺れたり いろんなことをしちゃうとね
修行成り立たない だからブラフマチャリアもつけちゃうんですよ
それで次の世代の弟子たちにその 3項目を教える
それでさすかその通りやと
それでその人も考える
道徳的に欲を抑えて生きるようとしたっても
ちゃんと勉強しておかなきゃもうわからへんでしょうね
だから勉強もしましょうということになっちゃうんですよ
そこで次の世代にその 4項目を教えてあげる
そこでよく勉強して よく修行して
だから順番逆になるんですよ
よく勉強して 正しい生活をして
修行して真理に至ると
真理に至ってもそれだけでは済まないと
人間として やっぱり人の役に立たないと
それからは ということでチャーゲ入れちゃうんですよ
だからもう思考パターンその思考パターンですよ
本当は仏教は逆に言うんですよ
チャーゲ それもっと優れていることすぐにやりなさいと
チャーゲの次にすぐ勉強しなさい
ただ 次に勉強するだけじゃなくて
道徳的にしっかりしなさい
それで足りません 修行もしなさい
それで足りません 真理を発見しなさいと
お釈迦様はそれを逆さまにして実践しやすい順番にしているんです
最初から真理と言ったっても
何がこれってことになっちゃうんです
しかし バラモン人が考えたのは
そういう順番で考えたことは確かなんです
確かではなくて 私がそう思います
それで問題は 伝統の中でそういう謂れがある
誰が最初に言ったかとこの青年も知りません
とにかく自分たちの伝統の中で
そういう 5つの項目がずっと流れてくる
それでお釈迦様が聞くのは
たった一人だけでも実証した人がいますかと
それが言ってから実証はダメですよ
言う前に実証してほしいんです
例えば私が言うんだったら
私が実証して言わなくちゃいけないんです
実はこういうことですよと
例えばこの青年が私が実証していますよと言っても
それはもう有効じゃないんです
実践していますよと言っても
君は実践するのは悪くないんだけど
それが正しいと誰か先生は言ったんですかと
そこで仏教のこの科学的って私は言う言葉なんですね
これは現代科学とは関係ない言葉なんですが
はっきりと実証しているかいないかと
だからパーリ語になってくると
ものすごい強烈にたくさん言葉を使ってます
サヤンアヴィンニャーね
自分で知ってちゃんと言ってるんでしょうかと
で そこ終わったところで
これはね あんた方はね
最初に言った人さえも分かってない
実証していない だから本当かどうかわからない
試さない限りは っていうことで
あんた前の人も知らない
次の人も知らない 次の人も知らない
次の人も知らないでみんな知らないんではないか
これはもう目が見えない人々の連続ではないかと
これはすごい厳しい非難になってしまうんですね
それで腹が立ったこの青年が
この超越した智慧があるというのはみんな馬鹿どもたちよと私の先生言ってますよと
いきなりお釈迦様をぶちこけちゃうんですね
超越した智慧があるというこういう人々はみんな嘘をついているんだと
そんなのはありえない
人間ですから 人間乗り越えられませんよと
人間乗り越えた智慧があるんだそうだと
いい加減な無責任な言葉ではないかと
そこをまたやられちゃいますね
お釈迦様 では このプッカラサーティさんがこの超越した人間を超えた智慧がある
人々の心を自分で知り尽くすって言ってますかと
だからそれ言うためにも
例えば私が人間を超えてる智慧は智慧持ってますよと言ったら
相手が嘘言うなよと そう言ってはいけませんよ
嘘を言うなよではなくて
あなた言ってることは嘘やと言うために
その人の証拠がないと言えないはずなんですよ
だからいつでも証拠がありますか？というポイントでいくんです
そこで私はいろんな人間にわからないこと
いろんなことを知ってるんだよと言ったら
私の心をその人は読めなくちゃいけないんですね
とにかく 能力を全部調べなくちゃいけないんですね
調べたところで証拠はありますから
もうあんた嘘を言ってるんだよと言ってもよろしいんですよ
だから同じ論理で このプッカラサーティはその超越した智慧を持ってる人々の全ての人々の心を読んでいるんでしょうか？と聞いたら
この青年がそんな奴はどれの心もわからない
あの召使いのあの女のことはわからないんだけど
おそらく裏で先生にぐちゃぐちゃ悪口言ってるかもしれません
これ弟子たちではよく知っている
あのバラモンじじい殺してやりたいとかね
と言って でもこの青年はそれを知っている
でも先生は全然知らない
あの女の人の奴隷の女の人の心も読まれてないんだよってことになってくるんですね
それでさらにバラモン人にも
そのポッカラサーリさんにも
お釈迦様は同じ理屈を出すんですね
私には見えないんだからありませんという論理だよと
だから私に見えませんだからありません
これが冗談じゃないんです
世の中でよくみんな言うんですよ
例えば輪廻に反対する人々が
人が死んだら生まれ変わりませんよと堂々と言うでしょうに
そんなのはわかりません
だったらしょうがないでしょうに
わからないことはいくらでも世の中にあるでしょうに
わからないんだから嘘やて言いたいんで
堂々とわからないんだから嘘やと言うんで
わからないんだというのは
それで私は認めますよ
だって私もわからないこといっぱいもうあるんだから
世の中で わかってるのは仏教の一部だけで
それも一部で こうチベットやら全然わからないだったりも
わからないものはいっぱいあるんだから
だからって嘘と言いますかね
私には飛行機の操縦はできません
だから飛行機の操縦っていうのは不可能なものであると
人間にできるわけないんだいと言えますかね
ということで よく我々その屁理屈も使ってますね
日常生活の中で だから私は厳しくそういうところを言ってますよ
だからもう思考を直しましょうと
この軽々くいい加減ですな思考ってのはよくないんだよと
軽々くいとも簡単に言っちゃうんです
そんなのは そんなのは現代人はもう認めませんよと
それだけでこちらもう捨てられているっていうことはね
仏教からもうもうとっくに捨てられてるんです
もう相手にならんぞと
現代人が認められませんと言ったって
何の理屈でもないんです
現代人っていうのは全知全能ですかね
現代人って大したことないでしょうね
この大したことない もう遊ぶことにしか知恵がない
もう人々が認めないんだからといって
今の若者は認めません
だから何ですかね そんなの認めてもダメだって勝手にしなさいよというでしょうに
事実は事実だからね だから現代人のそれは高慢だと私は言うんですね
高慢もかっこ悪い たちが悪い高慢なんですよ
昔の人ほども知識ないのに
観察能力はこのマインドコントロール世界で生きてるでしょうに
だからかわいそうな被害者たちですよ
現代人っていうのは自分で考えることは全くできない環境に生まれちゃって
もう言われたまんまでマニュアル通りに生きてるロボット人間でしょうね
現代社会っていうのは
だから被害者ばっかしでね
かわいそうで だからそういう人々にが
それなの自分の状況は
自分がマニュアルがないと何もできんなのに
我々はもうわかりません
認めません 故に嘘やと真理ではありませんというのはあまりにもたちが悪いんですよ
逆に私は調べて調べて調べてみたんだけど
わかりませんというのはかっこいいんですよ
しかしわかりませんと
それだったらあんたすごいしっかりしたものやと
よく頑張ってるんだよと
ということが褒めてあげることができます
だから 輪廻なんかに反対する人々
私は別に正当化してるわけではないんですけど
反対している人々の理屈も何も一つも成り立たない
あまりにも まあ無知な理屈になります
私に見えんだからありませんと
ということは 私が知るならば正しいということは
自分が全知全能という態度をとっているんです
人間そんな態度取れますかね
私は一切智者だよと 一切智者たる私が知らんのだから
そんなのはありませんという理屈ですよ
だからそういう理屈は昔お釈迦様使ってあって
見事に今の時代にも通用するんですよ
だからポッカラサーリさんにはそれを言ってないんですよ
ポッカラサーリがなんかよくよく考えちゃうと
生まれつき目が見えない人が人の話聞いて
青い色があるんだ 赤い色があるんだ
黄色い色があるんだ 綺麗なものがあるんだ
綺麗じゃないものあるんだとか言っちゃうと
自分に見えんだからそんなのはインチキ嘘やということと同じだよと
だからそれも思考を直すために
理性を育てるために必要な大事な思考なんですよ
やたらに否定するんじゃないんです
逆に否定するとしたっても
やたらに批判はダメでできません
かなりもう厳密でないと
この厳密さっていうのは難しくないんですよ
すごい単純に心を ものすごい単純な状態で保っておくと
それが智慧 いつでも智慧があるんです
ですから 例えば現代人が輪廻が否定したければ
いろいろ研究して 私はこういう方向で研究しましたよと
しかし成立はしないんだよと
で そのは仏教は一応いくらかなるほどとは考えてあげます
それの例は長部経典に一つあります
それはまあブッダ後の経典一つやとは言ってはいますけどね
まあまあ 経典の中でもお釈迦様が亡くなっているんだよと話も出てくるし
ある唯物論者がね もう唯物論だから物質が存在しない
霊魂魂はないと決まっているんです
それでも宗教家が言うでしょうね
霊魂魂があるんだと 死後はその霊魂魂は知らないでどこかに出て行っちゃうんだぞとかね
言うんだから この人はこれで腹が立ったんですよ
腹が立ったんですけど
まあ研究してみたんです
で この人はこの林でしたっけ
名前は なんとかという
まあ王子というか 王家の人なんです
だからいくらか人々を支配管理していた人で
だから自分のところに犯罪者なんか捕まってくるんですよ
だからこの人は処刑に決めなくちゃいけない
だからどうせ殺すんだからね
まずいろんな方法で人を殺してみたんです
魂を発見するんだと 人を死んだら出ていくんだからね
一つのことは この釜に人を入れて蓋をして
厳密に蓋を封印をするんです
封印をして 中で温めて
いろんなことでその人を殺しちゃう
もう死んでるんですね
例えばもう水をいくらか入れて
これものすごくもう熱にもう火につけて
もう当然死ぬでしょうに
釜の中だから またシール貼ってるんでしょうしね
水がなくても温めちゃえばね
それでパッと開けてみるんですね
考え方は魂があるんだったらふっと出てくるでしょうと
そんなのは見えなかったと
だから研究はちゃんとしていることはもうやっぱりもうしているんですね
一つはもう人には生きている人には魂がある
死んだ人には魂がない
では もう次の処刑人をね
測ってみなさいと きちんと測ったんです
測ったところで ではこの人の血一滴も逃げていかないようにして殺せと
まあ窒息させさせれば死んじゃいますからね
それで窒息させて殺しちゃったんですね
殺してからすぐまた測ってみたんです
だから生きてる時の体重はこれぐらい
死んだ時の体重 やっぱり例えば十グラム減ってます
から十グラム魂は重いとなるでしょうね
やっぱり魂がある それまた十グラムですよと
結果はどうですかというと
生きてる時は軽いし 死んだら重いんですね
この人はなんだこれと
魂が出ていくわけじゃなくて
もっと重くなっちゃったんだよと
そういうふうな研究して
この宗教家が言うのはもうとんでもない嘘やと言うんです
だからそれはそれなりにもう調べたんだからね
そういう理屈にどう答えるかという経典なんです
長部経典にあるんです
そこで坊さん出した例一つ
これなんですね ある人が立派な法螺貝を持ってきて吹く
そうすると四方八方震動しながら音が響き渡るんだと
ここでもう一人の人が来て
あんたの四方八方響きさせたあの音はどこから出したんですけどね
これ法螺貝ですよと 本当に法螺貝です
そうですよと言ったところで
法螺貝を裏から見て 後ろから見て
いろんな方向で音はどこにあるんでしょうかと調べる
見つかりますかと 音が
その人の実験は正しいと思いますかと
ということでもう否定されちゃいますよ
そこであなたは人はもうもう穴を開けてみたり
茹でてみたりとかね そんなのわからないんだよと
いわゆるその立場は 研究方法は間違ってるんだよということで
それでこちらよりも昨日終わったポイントはこの流れですね
何でしたっけ 私が知らないんだからないんだよという理屈は恐ろしいと
それは自分たちが何か知らないうちに
私が全知全能やと知らないものは何もあるはずがないんだよということになってしまうんですね
ですから 私がわからないんだからないんだよというんじゃなくて
単純に私にはわかりませんと
それでいいんですよ 正直にわかりませんと
あるいは一生懸命相手が説得してもしても
私は納得はいきませんと
そう言えばいいんです
だから真理を求めてる人はすごく簡単ですよ
正直になるだけです 例えば人がいろんなことを言う
言う 例えば品物を売りに来てね
こういうことすごい これはすごい
これはすごいとね 今買わなきゃ損だよとか
でも自分が別に買いたくはない
それは説明はもうありがとうございます
しかし 買う気にはなりませんねと
それは何ですか？これは言いませんと言っても
なんとなくなんか買う気にはなりませんと言っちゃえばいいんですよ
本当に一生懸命親切に説明する
それでまあご苦労様でしたと
私個人的にはね まあ悪いものじゃないんですよ
わかりますよと 素晴らしい
今買わなきゃ損ですよと
それもわかりますけど
買う気にはなりませんと言えば見事に正直だからね
だからやっぱり頭は小学生の以上持っていってはいけないんですよ
子供なんか人参食べませんよと言ったら
それどうしようもないんだから
それからはね 単純で これ美味しいですよとお母さんが一生懸命作っても食べません
だからそちらにはやっぱりまだまだ心は汚れてないんだからね
人間のちゃんとコミュニケーションの手段は
基本的なところはそのまま残ってるんですね
だから我々は頭がね いろんなことを勉強して汚したんだからといって
この思考の基本を忘れてはいけません
それで それから次にお釈迦様がこの青年をね
やっぱり育てなくちゃいけないんだから
どんどん二人が仲良くなって
このえらい対立して始めた会話なんですけど
ポッカラサーティさんに悪口言うところで
やっぱり若者もまあお釈迦様と一緒になっちゃうんですね
なんか先生に対して何か恨みがあるみたいですね
かなりやられただろうと思います
勉強 学生の時は まあそれはインド文化のことでね
まあ先生に悪口言いながら好いているんですよ
ブッダにさんざん悪口言ったりする
先生も一応知ってますよ
それぐらいのことは 知ってるんだけど
互いの愛情っていうのはなくなりません
ずっと一緒に生活するんだだから
まあ貶されるわ いろんな罰を与えられるわ
怒鳴られるわ もうキリがないんですね
先生のところも これ嫌で嫌で嫌ですけど
逃げていくわけにもいきませんし
だからまあもう隠れて文句言いながら先生に好いてる先生尊敬してないわけでもない
だから先生の悪口を相手が見つけたらえらい機嫌が悪いんです
ポッカラサーティさんの悪口はお釈迦様と一緒になって
あの人はこんなもんだよと言っちゃったんだから
お釈迦様はこの若者が青年がやっぱり気持ちとしてなんとなく自分の方向へ行ったって
その心の本能 微かなね
それは感じて すぐに仲良く話を続けていくんですね
エーワメーワコーマーナはこのような
この その通りだよ 青年
ガーマナポッカラサーティーオープマンニョーサブガワニコアンドーアチャッココー
ポッカラサーティサンガアンドーアチャッココー
目が無いんだと 目が見えないんだと
ソーワトウッタリマンサダンマアラマレーニャンラスナビセサンナニャッサティーワーダッカティワーサッチワーカリッサティネータンターナンヴィッジャティ
ポッカラサーティサンニワー
この超越した人間の次元を超越した知恵をね
経験する 体験できる 理解できるということは
ネータンターナンヴィッジャティありえません
目が元々ないんだからとと言って
タンキンマンニャシマーナは君どう思いますか？エーテーコーサラカーブラフマナマハサーラ
このコーサラ国には偉大なるバラモン人たちがいるんだよと
名前でいえばセイヤティーダンチャンキーブラフマナ
チャンキーというバラモン人
すごい大物ですよ タールッコーブラフマナ
またタールッカさん みんな大教授たちなんです
ポッカラサーティブラフマナ
ジャーヌッソーニーブラフマナ
ポッカラサーティさん
ジャーヌッソーニーさん
あ トーデーヤもいます
5人 それでピターワーテートーデーヤ
君の父はトーデーヤさん
この5人も巨大な人々で
巨大というものすごい大物のバラモンたちなんです
この中でもこの まあほとんどお釈迦様に会ったんですけど
みんな トーデーヤさんと会って喧嘩したこともあるし
チャンキーバラモンが仏教徒になりましたし
ジャーヌッソーニーも仏教徒になりましたし
まあ結局はもうポッカラサーティさんも仏教徒になったんですけど
みんな それで5人がいますね
カタマーネーサンセイヨ
その5人の中で誰が優れていますか
ヤンワーテーサンムサーワーチャンバーセイヤ
ヤンワーサンムサーティ
この偉大なる5人の中で誰が優れていますかと
嘘を言う人が優れていますか？嘘を言わない人が優れていますか？と言えばサンムサーボーゴータマ
やっぱり嘘を言わない人が優れているんだよと
カタマテーサンセイヨヤーテーマンターワーチャンバーセイユンヤンワーアマンター
その2人のこのどちらが素晴らしいかと
よく考えて調べてしゃべる人とまるっきり調べもない
ただしゃべる人 その2人で誰が偉いんですか？というと
やっぱり考えて調べてしゃべる人が偉いんだよと
カタマテーサンセイヨヤンワーテーパティサンカーヤワーチャンバーセイユンヤンワーアパティサンカーヤティ
次のポイント しゃべる場合はパティサンカーヤ
いわゆる根拠 裏付けがあってしゃべるか
根拠も裏付けも何もなくしゃべるか
どちらがすごいと言えば
やっぱり裏付けがあって根拠があってしゃべる人が素晴らしい
次にカタマンテーサンセイヨヤンワーテーアッタサンヒタンワーチャンバーセイユンヤンワーアナッタサンヒタン
これでしゃべる言葉はアッタサンヒタン
本当に有効的で意味のある役に立つ言葉をしゃべる
あるいは何の有効的もない
役にも立たない無意味なうわごとばっかりしゃべるならば
どちらが素晴らしいかと
やっぱり有効な有意義な言葉をしゃべる人が素晴らしいということになるんです
タンキンマンニシバ それでお釈迦様
ではあんたどう考えますか？タンキンマンニシ
だからよく見てください
とにかくこの若者の思考で持っていくんですよ
だから若者は仏教を理解したんですよ
だから現代人になぜ仏教を理解できないかというと
あまりにも腰抜けで自分の思考を出してくれないんですね
私はこういうことを知りたい
これは知りません これは何なのか
これはわかりませんと言わないんですね
あんた何言うんですか？じゃあ言ってみろという態度でしょうに
漫才に言ってるような態度でしょうに
笑わせてくれと それだったらもう全く仏教は理解できない
理解できないのはそれなんですよ
何か質問とか疑問とか
何か知りたいこととかね
あるいはただ偉そうな知識ぶっちゃって仏教
の中でと言ったっても
俺が勉強していないんだから必要性ないんだよと
そんなことじゃないでしょうに
私 例えば私にしてみたって
何か質問ありますと 仏教のプロやと思って聞くわけじゃないんですよ
仏教さっぱり知らない人ということを知った上で
知る必要もない あなた自身に何か疑問
問題 何か知りたいという本人の心
聞いてるんですよ それ出してくれなきゃ
もう永久的に檻の中にいることしかないんです
だから檻の中で餌くれと
そうすると食えるものも食えないものもあげます
私の気持ち次第だから
餌あげる人の気持ち次第だから
動物園の中に行ってみると
人間のやり方見えるでしょうね
檻の中に動物いると そこで動物を呼びたくて
そこら辺にいる葉っぱなんか取ってきて
もうするでしょう 動物全然寄ってこないんですよ
ちゃんと餌もらってよ
その場合はね でも見に行った人が自分の方向に寄ってもらいたいんだから
そこら辺の葉っぱ取ってそこに自分で動物取って食べられますからね
面白くないんですよ だからなんでバカなことするんでしょうかと
で 思ったりもしますけど
一応檻にいる人にあげる餌はそんなもんなんです
そこら辺にあるもの拾って
はいどうぞと ですから
やっぱりそうではなくて
自分やっぱり質問を出したり
対話をしたりしない限りは
ブッダの世界は理解できない
だからそれも分かってほしいんです
パティパダに書いたんです
サゲスとかサライゲスとかわかりませんだけど
ブッダは何を語るかと
ブッダを理解しようとしないでくださいと
だから もし私に疑問があったら仏教はわかる
私は精神的にイライラしたり
いろいろ不安定で あれも知りたい
これも知りたい ああいう歯ごたとかね
あざいらく悩みがやったりしてね
落ち着きのないないやらね
もういろいろあると まあそれが出してみれば
それに答えが出してくれる
それで あ なるほどという風にちゃんと真理がわかる
それがこの理解して それは真理を伝える方法でね
だから相手の 例えば私はギリシャ語で説法したってわからないでしょうに
ラテン語で喋ったってわからないでしょうね
喋りません 私もわかりませんから
ギリシャ語 ラテン語は
心配する必要ないんですけど
もし喋ったとしたってわからないでしょうに
だから日本語で喋らなくちゃいけないし
なぜ日本語で喋るかって
日本語がわかっているんだからなんですね
聞く人は だから私が知ってるものは喋るんじゃないんです
私は自分の国の言葉も知ってますけど
では 説法をその言葉でやりましょうか
国の言葉で 自分の国の
私知ってますから だから自分知ってるんだからとね
何の役にも立たないんですよ
でも現代人がお前が何知ってるんでしょうかと聞くんですよ
ブッダに対して それが現代社会ではこの智慧がないポイントなの
だから堂々と質問すればいいんですよ
反論したければ反論しちゃえばいいんです
でも怖いんですよ 反論したらどうしても反論されるし
批判しようと思うところで
さんざん確実に批判されますよ
それが怖くて じゃああなた知ってること教えてくださいということで
それでわからなくなりますよ
だから だからその怖さがね
できないんですよ もう質問出したら答えちゃうし
反論しちゃうとむちゃくちゃもうまた逆に反論される可能性が確実にあり
それでだから智慧がどんどんどんどん増えていきます
自分を守ろうと思っちゃうと
それではもう真理ではないんです
もともと自分がないんだからね
守る必要はないんです
では それでお釈迦様はこの青年にあなたはどう思いますかということを相手の気持ちで聞くんですよ
それで見てください 答えは全部この青年が出してますよ
考えて喋った人は優れているんだよと
根拠があって 裏付けがあって喋る人は優れているんだよと
役に立つことを喋る人は優れているんだよと
この青年が言ってるんであって
お釈迦様が言ってるわけじゃないんです
この青年の理解なんですよ
お釈迦様はちょっとガイドするだけ
整理してあげる 頭を 言葉っていうのは 2つに 2つに分けてあげる
すごい単純でしょ？白にするか黒にするかという感じで
難しくもないんです いきなり言葉
どんな言葉がよろしいでしょうかといきなりあの若者に聞きませんよ
若者はそんなに経験があるわけじゃないんだから
お釈迦様はそこで自分の知恵で整理してあげる
単純に それもこの選択 4つ
5つは出しません 現代世界だったら選択は五つか四つでしょうに
本当に時間の無駄ですけどね
だって質問する人はね
もうインチキは四つ三つ考えなくちゃいけないんだから
だから先生の頭が悪いし
学生の頭が悪くなっちゃうんです
お釈迦様はやっぱりYesかNoかの二つで
それできれいに整理するんですよ
それで自分が間違った選択したっても
その時点で正しいことは知ってるんです
だから時間はロスしません ABCD
でCやと思った 違ったっけというところになったら
ではAかBかDかということでしょうに
いまだに知らないでしょうに
それでまたあの三択の中で考えて考えて
やっぱりもしかするとAでしょうと
だから え ちょっと違いますよと
ああ それ違うか それとBとDの間でまた苦しまなくちゃいけないでしょうに
時間が無駄ですよ 時間という能力
全部考えたことは無駄でしょ
その間で 本物本気で質問だったらものすごく考えるでしょうに
それでAかBかと Aだよ A
はちょっとね やっぱりBですねと答えが出てくるんで
それだったらもう だから苦労が少ない
そういうことで お釈迦様はやっぱり二択に二択にして整理してあげる
本人が選んで選んでいけばいいんです
ヤディエワンサンテブラームネーナポッカラサーティナオーパマンジェーナスバガワニケーナサンムサワーチャバーシカアサンムサワーティ
だから見事にこのポッカラサンをけなしちゃうんですよ
それで君に聞きます ポッカラサーティさんが真理か事実を語ったんですか？嘘語ったんですか？アサンムサ
嘘を言ったんだよと 見事にまあいとも簡単に持っていくんですよ
マンターワーチャバーシカアマンター
考えて喋ったんですか？ちゃんと考えて喋った
考えない 喋る 考えないで喋ったんだよと
パティサンカーヤ 恨みあって喋ったんですよ
恨みなくって喋ったんで
恨みもなく喋っちゃったんだよと
アッパティサンカーヤ
アッタサンゲタイワーチャバーヤタアナッタサンゲタ
意味のある役に立つ言葉を言ったんです
役に立たない 役に立たないことを言ってしまったと
それで優れてないんだと
全くもただのジジイだということを言っちゃうんです
で まあそこでもうこの五人をまとめたのは
この人の機嫌をすごく和らげるためなんですよ
この偉大なるバラモン人の五人の中で
この人の父親もいるんですよ
トーデーヤさんが そこでその中でいくらかどう見たってポッカラサーティの方がちょっと態度がでかいんですよ
五人の中で どうせライバルだからね
このジャムソニという人がものすごい金持ちで贅沢で
それで威張ってるんです
誰よりも金があるぞと
で ポッカラサーティはかなりもういろいろ鋭いというかね
だからこのトーデーヤさんはそれほど立場がないんですよ
偉大なるバラモンだけど
だから自分の父親だからね
やっぱり子供にしたってもね
この五人の競争で まあやっぱりいろいろあるでしょうね
それでお釈迦様に見事にこの五人の中で誰が優れているんですかと
言って みんな抑えて偉くなってるポッカラサッティは何のことなく
全然優れてない いい加減な人やと
ただのじじいと もう言っちゃったんですよ
それも二人で仲良く喋り喋って言ったんですね
言ったらやっぱりあの人が今お釈迦さんにかなり侮辱されてもあったし
もう何のことなく もうもう仲良くですね
もう精神的には機嫌がいいんですよ
自分のお父さんもバカにしたりするんだけど
あのポッカラサッティ何あれって
嘘つきで 誰が気にするもんかっていうことでね
息子としてはね やっぱり機嫌がいいんですよ
そこでお釈迦様全部この話は置いといて
単純に仏教を教えてあげようということで
パンチャ・コ・イメマノ・ニーヴァラナ
ニーヴァラナっていうのは
この障害するもの 心の障害
智慧の障害 涅槃の障害
それからニーヴァラ ニワーレーティという動詞から来ている
ニワーレーティっていうのはこの蓋を閉めるということなんですね
何かに蓋をかけて閉めておく
心に蓋が五つあるんだと
だからもうわからなくなっているんですね
だから智慧の障害五つあるんだよと
それからこのただ勉強しただけで頭が良くならないと私たち言うのは
勉強する必要はいつでもあります
勉強すれば人間が大きくなって柔軟性になって
しかし それだけで良くならない
だからこのニーヴァラナっていうものは
それが何とかしないと
具体的に 確実に我々のこと心っていうのは自由にならない
蓋が五つ透けてもう閉めてますね
カタメーパンチャ・イッススワ・ナンナノ・コタ
カーマ・チャンダ・ニーヴァ
ヴィーアーパード・ニーヴァラナ
ティーナ・ミッダ・ニーヴァラナ
ウッダッチ・クックッチャ・ニーヴァラナ
ヴィチキッチャ・ニーヴァラナ
イメー・コーマノ・パンチャ・ニーヴァラナ
だからニーヴァラナあればもう智慧がないんです
choiceした智慧がまるっきりない
心は飛び出さないんですよ
自由にならない だから森の中ですごく自由に遊んでるゾウでも
鎖で縛っちゃえばもう何にもできないんだから
なんか渡り鳥でもね 白鳥なら色んなどこでも遠く飛ぶ鳥がいるでしょうに
もしほんのちょっと足とかなんとか縛っておけば
全部あの力がなくなっちゃうでしょうに
だから空をちゃんと飛んで
それまで飛んでいっちゃう白鳥でも
じゃあ翼には何かクリップでもつけておけば
飛べないようにクリップかけたりするでしょ
そうすると全部広げません
手は自由に入れれますけど
翼が広げません それで空気圧が足らないということで飛べないことにするの
するでしょうし それだけのことをやっちゃえば
もうもう飛べないんですよ
そんなように心っていうのは
人間の次元を飛ばしちゃって
ものを知ることはできますけど
これはもう五つの鎖でも縛られてますね
五つも切らなくちゃいけないんです
そこは大事なポイントです
だから仏教はあくまでも実証主義で
ですからガチャガチャブッダの話
誰が信じるもんかとかではなくて
君にこの五つはあるかないかと
まず調べなさい 五つ取ってみなさい
そうするとわかりますよと
一番目はカーマ・チャンダ
カーマ・チャンダっていうのは
この眼耳鼻舌身に入る情報しか情報がないぞと
いわゆるそこで 今はないんですけど
眼耳鼻舌身情報 この五つの目耳鼻口体
その五つから入る情報しか今私たちにはないんですね
で そこだけに我々は閉じ込められているんですね
それは破らなくちゃいけない
いくら瞑想修行したっても
やっぱり心が見るものには惹かれてしまうわ
聞くものに惹かれてしまうわというところがあります
だから それでカーマ 欲を断たなくちゃいけないんです
次にヴィーアーパード
怒りですね 怒りがあると事実は見えなくなります
怒りがある人は判断する
好きなものは勉強する
嫌なものは捨てる 好きなものだけ理解する
嫌なものは理解しようとしない
だったら真理はわからない
自分で判断しているんだから
くだらない もう未熟な心で
未熟な心で判断して 私はこれ勉強するぞと
それでは引っ張られる人間になるわけじゃない
だから怒りを断たないと
三番目はティーナ・ミッダ
ティーナ・ミッダっていうのはこの活性化していない心ですね
睡眠 昏睡 まあ怠けというかね
もう心はきちんと活性化しておかないとダメです
で 次にウッダッチ・クックッチャ
ウッダッチ・クックッチャっていうのは
まあ業行と義ですが いわゆるわかりやすく言えばもう混乱しているんですね
落ち着きがない 義があると落ち着きがない
あれ何だろう 何だろうとか
わからへんだろうとかね
という感じでいると もう落ち着きがない
落ち着きがない状態 で
ヴィチキッチャ まあ義そのものですね
ウッダッチ・クックッチャというのは後悔ですね
情交と後悔 それから疑いですね
疑い その五つあるともう心は成長しないんだよということで
イメーコーマーのパンチニーヴァルナ
これは五つの智慧の障害であると
ポッカラサーティ オープマンニョー スバガヴァニコ
ポッカラサーティさんがアーワトー ニウトー オープトー パリヨーナンド
イメーヒ パンチャヒ ニヴァルネーヒ
ポッカリサーダさんがこの五つの障害の中に陥って入り込んで
もうもうものすごく強烈に言うんですね
アーワタっていうのは囲まれてあって
ニウタっていうのはもうもうさらにさらにもう結ばれて結ばれて
もうもうとにかく五蓋しかない状態で
オープトー パリヨーナンドもう中に入り込んじゃって
もうもう立ち上がることもできんほど
あまりにも抑えられてしまってるんですね
ソーワト
ウッタリ マヌッサ ダンマ アラマリー ニャーンダスナ ヴィセーサン ニャッサティワ ダッカティワ サッチィ ワーカリ スレネータンターナング
だから彼には人間の智慧を乗り越えた智慧があるということは
まあ知ることもできませんよと
不可能ですよと そこで本当はこのこの若者にお釈迦様がこの五蓋は何なのかと
智慧の道は何なのかと説明しなくちゃいけないことになっちゃうんですね
全部説明していないとは思います
途中で省略しているんです
その経典は それで まずこの一番目
何でしたっけ？カーマチャンダ ニヴァルナ
欲の障害 欲の障害ですね
それについては説明しているんです
パンチャ コイメーマナはカーマグナ
カーマグナ 欲の対象は五つあります
それはチャックウェンイェンヤ ルーパ
目で見える形 それがイッター
美しい ハンター 喜びを持ってくる
マナーパ 気持ちいい ピエルーパ
また綺麗っていうことで
カームーパ サンヒター
またさらに欲が生まれてくる
目に入る形があります
美しい 綺麗で もう気持ちの良い
どんどん欲しがるような目に見えるものがあるんだよと
同じく耳で聞こえる美しい音がある
聞けば聞くほど欲が出てくる
それから鼻で嗅ぐ香りがある
嗅げば嗅ぐほど楽しくてたまらなくなる
それから舌で ジューハ
舌で感じる味がある 美味しい
美味しい 食べれば食べるほど美味しくてたまらなくなる
体で感じる感触がある
体で感じれば感じるほど楽しくてたまらなくなるという
これが五つのカーマグナですよ
だからカーマグナっていうのは外の世界ですよ
目に見えるもの 耳で聞こえる音
舌で味わう味そのもの
そんな五つがカーマグナですよと
ここでポッカラサーティがガティトー ムッチトー アッジョーパンノ
この欲張って欲張って
この五つに対して ムッチトー
もう無茶苦茶というかね
まあ大体同じ意味で 日本語でもね
無茶ですね まあムッチタっていうのは
やっぱりまあ何も判断しないで
もう無茶苦茶って意味なんですよ
アッジョーパンニョも入り込んじゃってる
アナディーナヴァダッサアヴィ
これは危険であるよと
まるっきり見ようともしない
まあ悪いことでも やっぱり悪いんですけど
やりたいなと思ってやっちゃって
いくらかあるでしょ ちょっとだけ
まあ後ろもだけど やっぱりちょっと若者でもたまに麻薬に手を出し
一回だけでもやっぱり知りたいなと
やでもこれはとんでもないことだから
一回にする それぐらいでもいくらか心に管理があるんですよ
それもないんだと 危険だと全然思えない
とにかくアナディーナヴァダッサアヴィ
危険であることはまるっきり見ない
アネッサラナパンニョ
どうすれば断てるかと
この断つことできるかと
このものが それも知らない
例えば酒飲み始めたんですけど
どうすれば酒が断てますか？それをもう研究してないだったらもう断つこともできない
麻薬を使っちゃうと 麻薬を断つ方法はわからないんだったら
もう断つことはできない
だからこの五欲をもう入り込んじゃって
貪ってね むちゃくちゃで楽しがっている
この人は五欲のこの危険性は全然気をつけない
それだけじゃなくて 五欲から断つ方法はまるっきり知ろうともしなかった
だから五欲を味わってはいけないということは言ってるわけじゃない
五欲はやっぱりアーディーナヴァダッサアヴィ
これは危険もありますよと
まあしかし こういう風にすれば逃げられますよと
両方知ってやらなくちゃいけないもんなんですね
五欲からは離れることできません
五欲から だって目があるんだから見えるでしょうに
どうせ見るんだったら
綺麗なもの見るのは誰でも私でも同じことですよ
見えるんだから じゃあ選んで選んで
汚いものばっかり見よう
全然しません どうせ見るんだったら綺麗なもの見るそうと
聞くんだったら綺麗なものを聞くそうと
昨日もインターネットでいろいろもうラジオ局やら調べて
日本はダメやと 綺麗なことを出してくれないと
といっても アメリカにコンタクト
アメリカのいろいろラジオ局で自分はこれはダメ
次の やっぱりどうせ聞くんだったら
気に入る音楽聞こうではないかと
だからそんなのはまあ別に誰でもやってることで
我々そういうことから離れることはできません
食べる時はどうしても味があるでしょうに
だったらまずいものをわざわざと何で選ぶんですか？どうせ味が感じるならだったらじゃあこれこれにするそうと
自分が好きなものを選んで食べる
それはもう避けられないことで
それはそれでいいんですけど
だからといってむちゃくちゃ美味しいものしか食わんそうと言って
あれも美味しい これも美味しい
これはやめなさいよと
たまたま 例えば美味しいものなくない場合は
それほど美味しくないものでも食べられるように
まあそういう精神的な訓練というのも必要ですよということなんです
そんなのはこのポッカラサイサンにはまるっきりないんだよと
だから彼がこのウッタリマヌッサダンマ
人間を乗り越えている智慧が走るということありえないんだよと
この五蓋の中で一番目はもう完璧にやられているんですね
それから残り 4つの説明は経典でないとは思います
まだ私も終わりまで読んでないんだからね
で やっぱりこの調子だったらないと思います
それでお釈迦様はすぐにこの説法は単純化するんですよ
イエス・ノーの単純な世界に持ってこないと
もう人間には理解できません
人間というか 誰にも理解できません
人間 複雑なことを考えているのは
それは明らかに偽善でインチキですよ
わかるはずがないんです
単純なものしかわかるはずがないんです
脳はそういう風にできているものなんですから
すぐ問題は単純に単純化するんです
タンキンマンジェシマノ
君どう思いますか ヤンワティナカットゥーパダンパティッチャアッギンパッジャレイヤ
ヤンワニッサッタティナカットゥーパダナアッギンジャレイヤ
だからヒガタス時はティナカッチャ
草やらこの薪やらね そういうものによって火が立つ
あるいはそういうものに何にも寄りかかることがなく
火が立ちますかと カタモヌカッサアッギアッチマーチャワンニマーチャパバッサローチャーティ
その中で一番綺麗な火は何でしょうかと
アッチマーっていうのはよく燃える
ワンニマーっていうのは綺麗な色
それから光もあると これどういう日本語？どうなってます？意味が通らなくなっちゃった
青年バラモンよ そのことをどう思いますか？つまり
草 薪の燃料によって火を燃やす場合と
草 薪の燃料を用いずに火を燃やす場合
どちらの火が炎を備え
光沢 光を備え 輝きを備えるものであるかということです
それでこのバラモン この青年にわからないことを言ってますよ
だから普通は火はね 薪で火を出すのが普通ですから
その薪で火を出す もし薪も何も使わないで火を出すと
君はどうなの？どちらの方がすごく綺麗に燃えるでしょうと思いますかと
でもこの若者はかなり論理的なんですよ
もうお釈迦様にも育てられたんだからね
そこでサチエ・ボウゴウともたあなん
ニッサッタティラカットゥパーダナ・アギッン・ジャリトゥン・ソアッサンギョ・アッチマーチャ・ワンニマーチャ・パバッサラ・オタ
もしできるならば この人まだ知らない
草やら薪やらで以外 火を焚てるっていうことは知らないんですよ
まあそれはまあもう掃除の世界でね
まあ今言えばガスでもできますけどね
まあそれは別として置いておいて
それでこれのもしできれば
薪やら草やらない状態で火を焚せることできれば
それはやっぱりさすが純粋な火で美しく輝くでしょうと
だってわかってるでしょうに
この草の癖がありますね
薪の癖もあるでしょうに
で 煙も出たり 火が立ったり立たなかったり
いろいろだからきれいな炎が出てこないんですよ
何かに頼ってるんだから
薪に頼った炎しか出てこないんですね
で この人は知らない 薪に頼らない日はあるかないかは知らないんだけど
論理的にあるならば もう邪魔がないんだから綺麗に輝くでしょうと
それでお釈迦様言うんですよ
アッターナン・コーエタン・マーナ・アナヴァカーソ
でもそれはできませんよと
薪やら草やら そういう何か頼るものをなく火を焚すっていうことはできませんよと
だからガスで火を焚いたっても
ガスに頼ってるんですよ
何かに頼らず火を作る
炎を作るっていうことはできませんと
アンニャーッタ・イッディ・マー
まあ人相だったらできますよと
それは超能力ですから
人相力だったらできますよと
タトゥーパ・マハン・マーナ・イマン・ピイティン・ワダーミ・ヤーヤン・ピイティン・パンチャ・カーマ・グネ・パティッチャイ
この五欲で美しいものを見て聞いて食べて遊んで楽しむ楽しみはお釈迦様は薪によってたす火に火だよと
いわゆる綺麗ですが 明かりもあるんだけど
やっぱりずっと薪に頼らないと
草に頼らないと かなり煙も出ちゃうし
炭も出ちゃうしね そういうところもあります
だからもう例えば暗いところで明かりのために火を立てたりする
寒いところで暖かくぬるくなるために火を立てたりしますけど
やっぱりその分苦労もありますよ
炭が出るわ 煙が出るわ
火が立ったり立たなかったりするわ
もうよっぽど出てくる
しかし 確かに日があって暖かいし
明かりがあるっていうことを認めます
そこで この五欲から得られる喜びは
薪によって立てた火と同じですよと
それからこの薪に頼らず
純粋に炎だけ作ることができれば
これが何の煙もない 炭もない
灰もない 大丈夫ですね
だからもう大きくなったり
小さくなったり 消えたりもなし
何にも頼ってない日だからね
でもそんなのは実際は作れませんけど
まずお釈迦様も断ってますよ
これ 超能力の人にはできますけど
普通はできませんよと
だからあくまでもこれ
論理上で持っていくんです
で それがこの 例えば人が五欲から離れると
この五欲から離れちゃうと生まれてくる喜びが純粋な炎と同じく
もう例えられないほど素晴らしいものだと
だから損はしていないって意味なんです
だから美味しいものも食べないで
美味しいものも見ないで
美味しい音楽も聴かないで修行すると
かわいそうで損しているんだぞとかね
こんなに楽しいのに 世の中はとか
それはなりませんよと
あんなのは楽しみでもなんでもない
苦労しているんだよと
だからもう煙ばっかしで
目がもう涙ばっかしで一生煙を立てる
あれ楽しいかと 何もなくパッと日が立てちゃうとね
そういうことで この欲から離れる喜びはね
そんなもんだよと そこで欲から離れた喜びって何なのかといって
この禅定のことを言ってるんですね
修行して 第一禅定 第四禅定
第三禅定 第四までですね
で 第二で終わっちゃうんですね
第二で喜びが終わりますよ
だからやっぱり見事にそこでストップしているんです
第三で喜びが消えるんですよ
四ではもう結果だけですからね
第一と二の禅定で すっごくもう喜びがもう上がってくるんですね
それまたすごい純粋な喜びで
それからお釈迦様はやっぱり五つは否定してはいけないんです
禅になる 禅に至る条件に否定してない
それからそちらに話をもっていくんです
五つはいいかもしれませんだけど
方法論やら確かめてない
まあいい加減というところは言っておいて
もっと真剣 真面目に喋りなさいよということで
イエ
ーテーマーノウブラームナパンチャダンメパンニャペンティプンニャッサキリヤエクサラッサーラーダナヤカミッタブラームナダンマンマハッパラタランパンニャペンテ
ィプンニャッサキリヤエクサラッサーラーダナヤーティ
それで若者 青年 そのあなた方の先生たちは五つを教えてるでしょ
禅に至るために その五つの中で大果ですか？一番大きい結果出す行為は何なのかと
それで答えはチャーガンエッタブラームナダンマンマハッパラタランパンニャペンティプンニャッサキリヤエクサラッサラーダナヤ
チャーガ お布施ですよと
五つありますね その中で最高な結果が得る善行為はお布施ですよというんですよ
それでそれから壊せますが
あのお釈迦様 わかるでしょ？バラモン人がどんな思考パターンで言ったかと
最後にチャーガが出たんですよ
だから最高ですよ わかるかどうかわかりませんですけどね
まあ昔の禅人たちが まず禅って何なのか
やっぱり真理だよと 嘘ではありません
真理 事実が先だよと といっても
というすぐにこれも必要だよと
といってもこれも必要だよと
それで勉強までも必要だよと
で 四つ出てくるでしょ
それで四つが実践したところで禅になっちゃいますけど
禅になってからは人々の役に立てないと
だから最高な最後の結果が役に立つことなんですね
だからどちらが最高ですかと聞いたら
この人はいとも簡単にチャーガだよと答えるんです
だから このバラモン人がどのように考えて
その思考を発展したかということは知った上で
お釈迦様はこの質問を出すんですね
だから相手もそういう答えを出すしか方法ないんです
仏教は逆の順番で読むんです
一番小さいのはチャーガで
一番大きなのは真理ですと
それ壊す過程は次にありますので
それから次に 一応覚えていらっしゃるのは難しいんだったら
いくらかこのこの経典を自分なりにちょっとメモでまとめてね
なんとか自分のためにね
内容これこれ まずこれ言って
まずこれ言って またこれ言ってとかね
そういう風にまとめてあると
私にとっては繰り返しなし
リピートなし 喋れますよ
いきなり喋っちゃうとちんぷんかんぷんで
ここまで繰り返したってわかってないのは見えますからね
ですからこの苦しいし
時間は無駄になっちゃうし
ですから 勉強したものはちょっと自分なりに自分のためにまとめるっていうことは悪くはないんです
この経典というのはそう簡単単純じゃないんです
ではもう かなり時間はなくなりました